[Musique]
henri salomon bonjour bonjour monsieur
kerriou vous êtes le président de la
chambre de métiers de l'artisanat de la
martinique est justement en tant que tel
puisque nous allons le rappelle nous
sommes dans un sac cadeau spécial
élections municipales et communautaires
donc en tant que président de la chambre
de métiers de la martinique ou titre de
votre fonction de votre mandat est-ce
que vous même vous avez des relations en
quelle relation entretenez-vous avec les
éditer des diverses municipalités et
celle des trois communautés
d'agglomération et bien l'artisanat et
par tout en martinique donc forcément
l'artisanat est en relation avec toutes
les municipalités déjà j'adresse un
message de félicitations à tous ceux qui
s'engagent pour l'avenir de la
martinique et je leur dis aussi de
penser artisanat et penser artisanat
c'est bien sûr va développer des projets
pour l'artisanat mais aussi sollicité
des artisans pour intégrer leur liste
des artisans pour être des référents
aussi sur des projets des municipalités
qui peuvent concerner le développement
économique alors répondu un petit peu à
une question que j'avais vous poser mais
nous allons l'approfondir tout à l'heure
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
est-ce que vous en tant que président en
fonction du mandat qui vous a été confié
donc élu pour représenter des
professionnels vous prenez parfois votre
bâton de pèlerin pour aller toquer à la
porte de tel mais route est l'adjoint au
maire
de tels présidents de communautés
d'agglomération et est ce que vous les
invités à venir vous rencontrer dans
votre bureau ou avec je suis plutôt un
homme de terrain donc avec mes équipes
de dépassant fréquemment donc pour allez
donc sur les territoires puisque la
chambre de métiers a de nombreux projets
maquis sont développées sur toute la
martinique ce que ce soit dans le nord
dans le sud est systématiquement nous
sommes très bien reçus parce que la
plupart des mères sont conscients de
l'enjeu que représente l'artisanat
l'artisanat c'est de la proximité et la
proximité ça se joue que j'allais dire
au coeur des municipalités avec cette
proximité est bien sûr il ya le
développement de la production locale
est forcément aux créations d'emplois
des propositions si de parcours de
formations telles que l'apprentissage
pour des jeunes donc l'artisanat est
très très très important et depuis le
début de ma mandature c'est vraiment
donc du nord au sud que je vais dans les
différentes communes pour proposer des
projets je pourrais vous donner des
exemples déjà comment par conséquent la
chambre consulaire elle-même elle est en
relation étroite avec donc soit des opci
enfin des communautés d'agglo ou donc
des villes ce partenariat
comment il se traduit quelle forme ça
prend est-ce que vous avez des
conventions d'aidé des contrats entre
ville vous voyez je concrètement comment
ça ça nous avons des conventions par
exemple nous avons signé une convention
avec la municipalité de fort de france
pour la création d'une rue des artisans
d'art excusez moi donc projet très
intéressant puisqu'il s'agit de faire
revenir des artisans dans le coeur de
fort-de-france trouver aussi des moyens
financiers pour leur permettre de
s'installer dans de bonnes conditions
d'avoir donc une rue des artisans d'art
qui soit vraiment un pôle d'attractivité
pour les touristes mais également pour
les martiniquais 7 pour ça pourrait se
multiplier dans d'autres communes à
vocation touristique et saz et ça se
multiplient donc que ce soit sur le
lamantin qui fait partie aussi du projet
coeur de ville mais aussi dans des
communes plus touristiques comme à saint
pierre
à sainte-marie également nous allons
être très prochainement présent donc
nous sommes en train de mettre en place
une médiane couveuse pour des
entreprises artisanales pour permettre à
des entreprises et bien de s'installer
d'avoir des locaux à des prix
raisonnables et bien ça se fera sur le
territoire de cap nord à sainte-marie
c'est l'une de nos actions et je vais
pas m'arrêter là dans le sud par exemple
à rivière-salée donc nous avons
développé un concept tout nouveau sur le
territoire la cité du goût et des
saveurs
là aussi nous avons besoin de
l'implication des ep six de la
municipalité de la collectivité
également et de l'état donc aujourd'hui
la chambre de métiers elle a le devoir
de travailler avec tous les partenaires
institutionnels puisque seul on est on
peut avoir de gros projets pour le
projet mais on n'est rien et lorsque
vous arrivez à convaincre les autres
d'intérêt votre projet et bien vous
faites votre projet aller beaucoup plus
loin vous êtes beaucoup plus pertinent
et surtout au travers de tous ces
projets c'est de donner du sens aux
activités artisanales puisque je vous
parlais de de création d'emplois de
production locale plus nous allons
produire en martinique donc produire en
proximité plus nous allons enrichir la
martinique parce que nous allons créer
des emplois et permettre à des jeunes de
rester au pays pour pouvoir y vivre
alors votre défi c'est de fédérer
quasiment tout le monde en tout cas les
uns les unes et les autres autour de 2,2
ce projet séduisant sur le papier alors
on va pas y revenir nous avons on vous a
entendu en début de propos incitent et
encourager les artisans chefs
d'entreprise à être candidat colistiers
ou pourquoi pas mais mieux encore ce
sont les mieux placés pour parler de
l'artisanat et donc moi je les invite à
le faire je sais que la vie de chef
d'entreprise artisanale
c'est compliqué parce qu'on doit tout
faire pour mettre le commercial la
production le service après-vente la
comptabilité et trouver du temps pour
s'investir pour saisir une action
civique c'est difficile donc j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour ceux qui
arrivent à le faire est vraiment c'est
un message que je lance à tous les
politiques
appuyez-vous aussi sur des artisans pour
vos projets de développement économique
eux savent donc profiter de leur
expérience pour écouter les et puis bien
sûr au delà des coûte agissez henry
salomon vous le président de la chambre
de métiers et de l'artisanat de
martinique quel regard vous portez d'une
manière globale 1 il s'agit pas de
cibler telle ou telle commune ou tel ou
tel territoire mais quel regard vous
portez de manière globale sur la
politique la politique de la ville mais
en fait on en appelle ça comme ça mais
c'est une politique qui s'adresse
surtout aux quartiers pauvres des villes
et des communes par rapport aux
installations de zones artisanales ici
ou là comment vous vous faites pour que
ce soit intégrée par exemple dans des
plans locaux d'urbanisme les fameux paix
à lui ou les plus comme on dit enfin
vous voyez est ce que voilà par rapport
à tout cela
aujourd'hui et j'ai les airs depuis
trois ans nous nous battons pour faire
comprendre qu'il faut développer des
zones d'activités spécifiques pour
l'artisanat c'est à dire il ya des lieux
où on doit pouvoir trouver des artisans
facilement les foires et terrain il faut
le foncier tout ça fait exactement shell
et vous voyez pour que ces artisans
puissent s'installer ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'il y ait une volonté politique
accompagné bien sûr de moyens financiers
mais tout commence par la volonté et ça
donc c'est notre discours depuis le
début de la mandature
c'était même un discours j'allais dire
qu'ils étaient là avant mon arrivée mais
nous l'avons amplifié nous avons sur le
terrain
nous avons proposé des projets concrets
que ce soit sur le territoire de
l'espace nord de la cacem ou de l'espace
sud pour créer des zones d'activités
artisanales très bien alors il ya les
créations bien sûr il il en faudra on
sait sur sur notre territoire sur notre
île mais j'entends certains artisans qui
disent que certaines zones artisanales
mériteraient également des rénovations
c'est à dire qui en a qui sont là mais
qui bon avec le temps bon ben voilà il
faut vous avez raison et c'est pas que
des zones artisanales qui mériterait des
rénovations et c'est toute la martinique
est aujourd'hui c'est un formidable défi
que de rénover
nos structures rénovées des centres
bourgs alors déjà ça serait une bonne
chose pour les martiniquais et puis ce
serait aussi une bonne chose pour les
entreprises artisanales du bâtiment qui
ont besoin d'activités je rappelle qu'il
ya des fonds qui arrivent comme dans le
projet coeur de ville ou tout récemment
avec action logement des fonds qui vont
permettre de financer ou d'accompagner
financièrement des projets de
construction de logements à ses projets
de construction de logements c'est mon
discours il faut associer aussi d'aider
des locaux professionnels permettre même
d'habiter à l'endroit où mon travail à
l'état joue dessus ou juste à côté
voilà donc une façon de redonner de la
vie au centre ville les centres villes
de martinique sont souvent désertées
l'une des solutions donc il pourrait
très efficace c'est de faire revenir les
artisans sort ses centres villes et
quand je dis ça donc je m'appuie aussi
sur des chiffres aujourd'hui nous sommes
en pleine progression concernant la
création d'entreprises donc nous avons
plus 10 % d'entreprises créées ces
entreprises souvent ce sont de toutes
petites entreprises des micro
entreprises artisanales
elles n'ont pas de locaux les artisans
sont obligés de travailler chez eux
des études ont dix jeunes artistes
recevoir mais des zones commerciales et
artisanales ou inversement zone
artisanale et commerciale mais je dire
une fois qu'on a créé son sont produits
d'artisanat d'art il faut le
commercialiser faut le vendre vous faire
en train de sonner il faut être dans un
endroit où on puisse entrer facilement
voilà les artisans donc on a parlé des
centres villes qui est avec toutes ses
dents creuses qui pourrait être occupé
par des entreprises artisanales
ça doit être un choix politique avant
tout moi je le défends tant que
président de chambre de métiers j'ai des
nombreux artisans qui sont prêts à
s'installer dans ses nouveaux types de
logements ou au coeur des villes et pour
ça donc il faut qu'il y ait un programme
pour rénover et surtout pour permettre à
ces artisans d'y accéder à des coûts
raisonnables
c'est comme pour des habitations à loyer
modéré aujourd'hui il faut condamner des
espaces de travail des espaces de vie à
loyer modéré ou à coût d'accès modérée
pour les artisans et si on fait ça on
crée de l'activité en redonner une image
positive à neubourg à notre martinique
on enrichit le pays parce que ces
entreprises qui se créent et bien à
l'embauché des jeunes des moins jeunes
donc ça sera moins deux personnes
donc ils vont vivre des minima sociaux
et surtout on développe notre production
locale donc c'est tout bénéfice pour la
martinique
il faut investir pour créer les artisans
puissent installer correct allait il
nous reste moins d'une minute henry
salomon on a déjà entendu donc un
certain nombre de vos requêtes de devaux
projette vos souhaits pour la prochaine
mandature là qui s'annonce donc pour les
communautés d'agglomération et les
municipalités
quel autre souhait important vous auriez
pour ces six ans qui arrive alors il ya
un message qui en quelques secondes
malheureusement qui va être diffusé à
tous les maires de martinique c'est
d'accueillir un village artisanal lors
de leur manifestation donc tout au long
de l'année donc une fois par an par
commune
nous sommes en train de mettre en place
un nouveau produit donc ça va s'appeler
le village artisanal des artisans de
l'alimentation de la fabrication a bien
qu'ils vont pouvoir être au contact du
public
la municipalité nous fournit un espace
sûr pour qu'ils puissent exposer et nous
nous fournissons long des artisans donc
avec des produits intéressants à montrer
à la population
on est déjà impatient de voir un de ces
villages artisanaux et bien fleurir
tiens 1 le terme est beau dans une de
nos communes et puis ensuite ça se fera
certainement dans les 33 autres merci
henri salomon président de la chambre de
métiers de l'artisanat de la martinique
d'avoir répondu à nos questions dans ce
ca au caddie spécial élections
municipales et communautaires une
émission réalisée par jean louis bongo
merci